how do you plan on fighting Ferguson
same as always man I gotta put that dude
asleep no I got that Mike Tyson Powers
watching Samia dates man you're gonna
put some guys to sleep I want to be a
legend like you Mike are you going top
Mike are you and don't find buddy my sir
good to see you again
thank you brother but started you ready
married tell me
Justin tell her you've done so quickly
man are you happy with it I'm pumped man
you know uh as fires me fight for world
championship that's what I got in this
for so I'm a gambling man I'm a gambling
man I'm a rolling dice yeah I think it's
a good opportunity for you oh absolutely
if you defeat further than who you want
to fight men I wanna be my want the best
of the world oh man I right we found I
want to be a legend like you Mike all
right he's going after the right one man
I'll check you guys the manager comedian
both man's barley did then make it to
lead back out B yeah that man is our
best interest in his mind and he knows
that we fight for one thing and that's
four world titles I don't think he would
ever have a problem with two of his
athletes fighting to be the best in the
world for when he gets paid twice which
I would never complain about and for to
uh he's making his athletes dreams come
true and that's his job and moving I'm
really I'm really I'm really happy that
there will be a big moment for you and I
think great advantage of it yeah I've
been working this this is a long
combination of events and um you know
it's not the end but it's uh it's a
steep climb right now how do you get the
deal on such short notice
how do you get in shape you very much
the been in shape already been working
yes you know uh I've been telling myself
since my last fight that I was gonna
fight again
you know I will fight again and it will
be a huge fight so I I was able to stay
focused you know I wasn't doing a
hundred percent of what I would be doing
because I believe that's impossible
without the actual target in sight you
know um this wasn't necessary in there
but like I said I'm a gamblin man and
you know I've been working since I was
four years old and fighting and fighting
it only takes one shot in you know I got
that Mike Tyson power so I just wanted
to be a date man you really put some
guys to sleep
I uh I think I've reached I think eight
guys have never fought again after they
fought me because I can see why man they
may have brain contusions I think they
just I think it's PTSD they know ever
want to experience what they experienced
and they're with me absolutely great so
how do you plan a fight in Ferguson same
as always man I gotta put that you to
sleep
he's a cardio machine I'd be a fool to
say I got I got 25 minutes of cardio in
me right now but I've been scheduled for
16 or 4:00 I don't even know how many 14
15 16 5 round fights I've never gone a
distance and I never plan on this since
I'd rather lose I'd rather get knocked
down the second they weren't a decision
in the fifth listen what about car you
would like to frame Connor I would like
to fight a beep okay I would love to
fight Connor I want to punch him in the
face absolutely he's a superstar
marijuana I want to take his shine
that's what I'm here for
holy moly looks good right thank you I
told everybody be careful if they want
to jump on this rollercoaster because
there's no there's no uh there's only
you know how it is we crash and burn
baby that's ok but we don't have to die
so we don't know we don't that's why I'm
pumped is 4:20 right after my a fight
I'm gonna be celebrating like a
[ __ ]
I wish you the best of luck
congratulation Mike I hope you watching
man I promise I'm gonna watch it
waiter lose you're gonna love it you
gonna win you gonna win it I'm a lovely
even more yes sir never gonna smoke a
blunt big time
alright Mike thank you see brother it
survey later yeah like that [ __ ]
up
yo or damn it guys thank you yes sir
your legend love you Jeff